it's nostalgia tree trunks here she is
somebody made this for me at Akane sir
but my but also has a bow on it so it's
pretty cool um but yeah I said lands
feet long I would show that off so it's
really really cool so just uh thanks
again for them and good put that over
here with that said this is James to the
follow up to the kind of controversial
episode really I thought was kind of
controversial you know even Finn and
Jake broke a leg is this a good thing or
a bad thing
like I don't know and this one it's
almost like they took the controversy of
it and just said we're just gonna push
it to like ten and we're just gonna like
not care and go batshit insane I thought
was kind of funny actually I was and I a
part of me really says I should know
better but I I was laughing at a lot of
this pretty much James to supposedly
keep saving bubblegum from stuff but
it's almost never a trial even know what
the hell he saved her from like in the
beginning like exactly pushes her out of
the way and then he's in the water going
off a waterfall so we even know if he's
really saving her um remember he saved
her from that toxic much uh muffin if
remember okay I got things yeah and
examine a create the whole thing so yeah
you just forget the idea that
something's up so she finally says well
I can't keep cloning James so you know
I'm giving him medals every time I bring
him back so we gotta just stop this you
know we're gonna go and empty out his
apartment and finish it go and turns out
those and I write those James were not
most of the James's were not actually
dying they were just going back to the
home right is that what yeah NGH exit
she kept cloning him and then the real
James number two just like getting met
also he just collected them he has like
this big necklace of just a ton of
metals even though like he hasn't he's
probably not the one who's been doing
them you know right one of the other
James's but they're all so stupid they
don't care so people's finds out gets
really angry and tells all the banana
guards you know to go after this James
and Finn and Jake for the most part just
watching a lot of us go by
even convinced people's to just just
watch the stupidity of it all and so
they're watching they're kind of
enjoying it and then zombie James comes
back and he brings all his other
jelly donut zombies to try and destroy
them all and all the James's kind of get
together and they jump on top of zombie
James and formed this giant collection
of all of the James's she gives him all
the medals and says your next mission is
get out and never come back they go okay
and they they just take off well
remember she promised that as long as
you stay away yeah I shall keep sending
medals like every day which for the
economy I wonder how much that cost
everybody's made of candy it's like what
is what does metal cost in this world
you gotta think about it tell his money
in this world there's anything Oh
where's he he was in that apartment or
whatever yeah but if he leaves never
comes back there's no address oh I
didn't
yes oh yeah send you a medal every day
yeah go away well he could always come
back and demand but that's all done
waiting for no no games three no no she
can say it's in the mail oh okay that he
goes back wait a minute
that would be pretty funny and it's like
a weekly race yeah it's always like a
week later he keeps coming back so yeah
there's the humor in this episode I tell
myself this is really dumb and I
shouldn't be laughing at it but for some
reason I really laughed at it ah I think
it's something about having Finn and
Jake just sit back and watch it I think
even there's something reassuring that
even the main characters note you know
what this is a pretty silly existence we
have sometimes you just gotta take a
step back and laugh and so much and this
is what that was it's just watching the
banana guards and all the James's
interact with each other you see them
build a great big device you have no
idea what its gonna do and it does
nothing it just falls apart which is
great I loved it when I loved the build
up but when they just go in there
waiting for people to go in and into the
apartment
it's so quiet that just the door opens
up hey and they just see all moving out
the window running around and they're
just laughing it's just I like that joke
because you're kind of thing they're
gonna do something different like here
it comes like they're building it up and
usually nowadays it's you don't deliver
the Joker you delivery something
different yeah they just deliver exactly
what you're thinking but it's like it's
still done so well and and it's really
funny um I love kicking the kids over
the wall that was great it really kind
of felt like like it felt like you know
one of the really early Adventure Time
episodes because there's one scene where
it's like you know we should all be
called the same thing - and the the
banana cart just gets really tea right
just make things much easier I'm sorry
anyway and it's like what was that about
and it was just so random and so strange
it reminds me when that gingerbread
cookie kata-kata oh look we that crazy
guy you know it's worth toter yes that's
how we found out more about him but like
back there we have no idea what the hell
think he was or what his story was or
what he was doing um so yeah I even
Bella who is really on the fence with
the first James I think because this one
so didn't give a crap it just went so
far with making so many of these James's
I mean now they're all kind of one thing
or whatever and it was like the first
one is such an ethical dilemma now it's
just so bad chin saying I kind of
respect it for just going all-out crazy
so yeah I I surprised me really liked it
we should say got it James still annoys
the hell out of you but it's not
annoying in the way of like lemonhope or
lumpy Space Prince like he's got that
almost lovable annoyance to him where
it's like oh I'd actually hang out with
you for a little bit and then I just
push you out the door
so seeing a whole bunch of James it was
kind of like ah but no I loved the
banana guard
James interaction that was great in the
whole I don't remember
blah blah blah septuplets or something
like that I'm like what other than PB
just being with us top what the hell
like I just love her annoys with them
right though I love the way that Finn
and Jake are just like I'm missin
earring chillin just we're just gonna
watch it it's all good it's okay
there's something nice when they invite
people's to do I feel like you know you
need to relax a bit you need to just
take a minute just to you know look at
the ridiculousness of the situation and
have a good giggle yeah yeah it's
somehow that made it even funnier I
think if if they weren't watching when
she went in and they all jumped out like
it would still be kind of Flav I don't
think it'd be as funny there's something
about they know what's gonna happen I
think that just adds to the buildup for
me it was more along the lines of like
you were sitting there with your buddies
be watching it you know instead of just
being the observer like you're almost
like sitting there with Finn and Jake
cuz you're like okay let's go gun okay
oh wait something's gonna happen you
know I just felt like at least for me
like I was there with them and that's
some so weird
no it's like it's kindly Mystery Science
Theater yeah like you're with them
watching the bad movie and kind of you
know is sharing their pain or their
laughter or what yeah and I like how it
was done and I think it was smart with
that scene where they did it where James
and Peebles were like far away and they
were small yeah I think that added to
the humor just like these tiny things
jumping out of windows coming yeah I
just heard right you know running out
we're but wait you can see how many of
them are running out and then yeah the
annuda Johnny it was very well animated
for something I was so tiny yeah um you
know why I think the reason why I didn't
find James as annoying in this one as
opposed to the original it sounds
strange but I think because there are so
many of them it makes it a little
funnier if there's only one banana guard
I don't think that'd be funny
III think he'd get annoying really fast
but the fact that there's a ton of them
something about the collective stupidity
is just hilarious oh I agree
III think it's funnier because it it
sounds more like even with all these
people they couldn't put a thought
together there is a sense of Halloween
special where it's like it was just at
the point where it's like starting to
get annoyed with Homer you know it's
like oh man this guy's we starting to be
a pain but there's one where there's
like just a ton of clones of him and
they all just do the same thing but it
was really funny I mean it's so
funny seeing all these homers all go
into a bar go Coco and then they all at
the exact same time run out to go around
the corner pit you know to take your
pictures ago why be just all of them
going around the corner like that it's
hilarious you'd have to be there and it
would be funny make even you life you
Simpson hater no just watch the missed
the episode where there's multiple Tom
servos I saw the one where they put him
in the phone booth I was like I do it he
tries to stuff himself in a phone booth
so he just has all these time servers
maybe it was a reference to that I don't
know I I actually really dug this
episode I thought I was surprisingly
fond it yeah again a lot more laid-back
mm-hmm you know with the last you know
stuff though it's been going on which is
a little bit more heavy nice and
laid-back
yeah really good I like the balance
that's back yeah that's not heavy heavy
heavy heavy heavy light heavy heavy
heavy heavy where it used to be the
other way around yeah I I think this is
a needed episode honestly when I saw
James - I was are like need another not
only heavy but with an annoying
character but like I said I think having
a lot of them really did help yeah
there's just something funny about big
group of stupid people that there is
with just one stupid feel like all the
channel awesome exactly know I drew
there's a lot of truth to that honestly
no but I'm that's why no I love doing
the anniversary's not because the real
people are stupid but because I love
getting these characters these big you
know clearly show on their reviews that
you know they have big egos are angry
and they're hating on stuff when you get
all those people together and they just
want to bitch and moan and complain it's
it's hilarious
I mean and that's why I love doing the
anniversaries of that because I love
seeing all these characters together
sort of interact off each other even if
it is just one doofus cloned a million
times yeah they're still working off of
each other and I think it's just
hilarious so yeah no I thought was a
really good closing thoughts no good
good don't make me use my sexual wise
and as real as you want me to be
god you're lucky that that someone gave
you that I'd break it do me in the bow